موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قواتها تتقدم من الجهه
الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه شرق اوكرانيا
ياتي هذا بينما وصف رئيس شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه يافجيني الوضع في
باخمت بانه صعب للغايه مضيفا ان
الاوكرانيين يتشبثون بكل متر في المدينه
ويصلهم الدعم دون توقف واكد ان التقدم
يستمر في المدينه بفضل قواته وبفضل السلاح
الروسي
من جهاته قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
الوضع حول باخموت لا يزال صعبا مؤكدا ان
وحدات فاجنر الهجوميه تتقدم من عده
اتجاهات واكد خلال جوله تفقديه على الجبهه
الشرقيه ان قواته صدت الضربات الروسيه
والحقت خسائر كبيره بالقوات المهاجمه
في تونس اختار نواب البرلمان الجديد
ابراهيم بودرباله رئيسا للمجلس باغلبيه
الاصوات متقدما على منافسه عبد السلام
الدحماني وكان البرلمان التونسي قد عقد
امس جلسته الافتتاحيه وسط احتجاجات في
صفوف الصحفيين بعد منعهم من دخول البرلمان
لتغطيه الجلسه وقد اعلنت جبهه الخلاص
الوطني وحركه النهضه عدم اعترافهما بهذا
البرلمان
والتمسكهما بدستور 2014 مصدرا وحيدا
للشرعيه
هذا وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان على
المشرعين الذين بشروا اعمالهم في مجلس
النواب ان يضعوا التشريعات المناسبه
لاراده الشعب الا ينسوا ان الشعب قد يسحب
منهم الوكاله بعد سنه اذا لم يلتزموا
بوعودهم بناخيهم حسب قوله وقال الرئيس
التونسي انه ستقع محاسبه من يعتبر نفسه
امتدادا لحزب او تنظيم او مجموعه ما لان
المرافق العموميه تقوم على مبدا الحياد
وقالت نقابه الصحفيين التونسيين ان منع
الصحفيين من دخول البرلمان سابقه خطيره
ومصادره لحق مقبول بدستور ووصفت نائبه
رئيس النقابه الوطنيه للصحفيين التونسيين
اميره محمد منع الصحفيين من تغطيه الجلسه
الافتتاحيه للبرلمان بانه وصمه عار في
مسيرته الجديده على حد تعبيرها
ختام المجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]